I'm running for president
so I'm hitting the road to earn your
vote powerful courageous fierce
conservative
Hilary Clinton has been a proponent for
fracking she voted for the Patriot Act
she came out in defense of the NSA after
the Edward Snowden leaks and she's been
a proponent of terms she's really not a
progressive candidate I love Hillary
Clinton but I feel like I know more
about Elizabeth Warren and I feel like
she really identifies a lot of issues
that I really care about like student
loan debt there's not many other people
that could be a viable option because
she has the most experience out of
everyone it's the lesser of two evils
she is my friend I think she would be an
excellent president
you